[Music]
hey everyone so I just want to let you
guys know that we decided to close all
JK operations and offices on March 20
when the LA mayor called for a strict
stay at home order luckily we had a
stockpile of videos to last us for a few
weeks so our operations were able to
continue that's right baby
so now that we've been home for over 20
days and now our stockpile is completely
dry we had this huge decision that we
had to make so Jo and I spent several
hours having multiple phone
conversations on what to do so we spoke
with all staff regularly and we
monitored everyone's activity and health
we have decided to reopen our office for
two days to film another stockpile with
the mixed cast of people who we feel
have been following the quarantine rules
the most and offered the least risk to
their peers so some of our staff have
family members and spouses that either
work in grocery stores or medical jobs
and we've asked them
um politely stay your ass is at home
we've had some cast members that have
had symptoms so we've also asked them to
stay home on politely on politely so our
plan is to film a bunch of videos for
these next two days and then quarantine
again for a two-week minimum we feel
this schedule will help reduce the
spread while allowing us to keep
operations and let our staff keep their
jobs so we talked about trying out zoom
and doing JK news that way but what we
realized is the way that this company
operates is by posting volume on YouTube
the logistics of doing this on Zoom is
still something we're trying to figure
out and it might be a possibility in the
future so we are doing our best to
mitigate imbalance issues from many many
different directions number one being
healthy and keeping everyone else
healthy number two is continuing to
provide and maintaining jobs for over 20
people because we have no idea what the
future is going to hold actually I
wanted to be a hundred percent sure that
we're legally able to operate so I even
called the City of LA mayor's office to
make sure that we were legally able to
continue to operate under the stay at
home law so all media include
podcast and even radio they're all
listed we do know that we're not
necessarily an essential business but we
are operating legally and all staff who
are participating are doing so because
they want to so just so you know no
one's being pressured to come to work
that's right most people were like I
can't wait to come back I make all our
data what is sanitized evil yeah what
actually ended up happening was we we
had a strict rule of criteria and a lot
of people couldn't be here that wanted
to be here the team members that are at
high risk we know that that's not their
fault and we want to watch their backs
too so everyone's getting paid at a
minimum rate just so they can survive
through this chaos please understand
that we're taking this very seriously
and we are doing our best to make the
right decisions while providing still
the same jakie news that you guys are
used to seeing without any crazy changes
because I know how hard it is to be in
quarantine and you have absolutely
nothing to do we're just trying to be
that small pocket of joy like from pre
quarantine life that you always had that
familiar routine that you always did
like listening to our butt hole stories
[Music]
you
you